I'm more excited about Jan and Alex
pierra so my head's going John's bigger
dude he has more MMA fights he can take
him down and this thing pretty easy but
my heart's like dude I hope Alex Pierre
wins he gave him the one fight that's a
kind of a disaster form and yawn in MMA
I am very curious to see what pereda's
uh punch resistance looks like at 205.
like dude this this division at the at
the top is kind of a mess with you know
Hill got injured I feel bad for Hail
then Yuri had a whole thing he's coming
back so you've got Pereira Yan ankali of
rakich coming back walker I mean dude
you know to me it seems like the
division has like what okay doesn't have
a dominant figure and I think that's
always better to have a dominant figure
but I ain't mad at a little bit of
parody and some fun matchups if the UFC
or the fights could shake out in a way
we can get those